aujourd'hui je viens vous parler de
quelque chose que j'ai dans l'aura ici
c'est les nouveaux sony ling bugs je
vous explique le principe qu'est ce que
c'est que c'est sony lingen ce sont des
petits bugs mais ils ont une
particularité qui en font vraiment un
truc assez intéressant c'est à dire
qu'ils sont ouverts ouvert physiquement
factor s'est pas vu des micros qui a
nagé quelles sont ses leçons qui passe
via un petit trou au centre donc l'idée
plutôt bonne sauf que lorsqu'il ya du
bruit lorsqu'il ya du monde autour de
moi lorsque je vais me balader comme ça
dans la rue et bien sûr entendre donc le
truc qui est cool c'est que bâche
toujours osé gay et j'entends ce qui
passe autour de moi donc du coup je peux
rapidement savoir si une voiture s'il ya
des gens et ça c'est plutôt cool le
point un peu négatif maintenant de
l'histoire c'est que lorsque vous avez
beaucoup de bruit des voitures justement
qui passe de tous les côtés et qui a un
truc qui peut être un peu dérangeant 30
par une voiture qui passe de l'entente
j'ai coupé la musique pour vous parler
eh ben c'est que je l'entends et que tu
alors là il était en train de vider du
verre dans une benne et ben j'entends
donc voilà donc ça sert tout cas
première donc si vous êtes par exemple
dans un métro que vous vous baladez vous
avez le bruit du métro et c'est juste
hyper relou si vous êtes avec beaucoup
de bruit autour d'eux ou se compliquer
si vous êtes dans la campagne ben il ya
un côté qui est sympa parce que vous
entendez les petits oiseaux à côté de
vous mais voilà ça dépend vraiment des
cas de situation ça allait prendre une
vache si vous allez courir par exemple
dont vous entendez ces passe autour de
vous et ça c'est bien ce que c'est pas
un micro cloud injecté leçon c'est le
son d'un point de vie naturel donc voilà
un peu l'idée voilà un peu l'histoire
ont plus de ça nous aura joué en tout
cas c'est marrant c'est que vous n'avez
pas de bouton pour direct dessus vous
appuyez sur votre tête là par exemple
j'ai pris deux fois son a trop chaud
donc la salle mais la musique donc l'âge
et de la musique en même temps je vous
parle mais en même temps je m'entends et
j'entends se passe autour de moi et si
je veux arrêter de faire deux fois voilà
ça coupe le son donc y'a un côté un peu
marrant donc on va regarder déjà comment
c'est fait je vais vous montrer je vous
ramène au studio je monte comment ça
fonctionne je vous montre d'un poilu
physique à quoi il ressemble il ya une
application aussi qu'ils écoutent ça
c'est chez sony sa retraite des femmes
belles applications donc là y'a pas de
problème maintenant est des choses qui
vont il ya des choses qui vont pas et
c'est justement ce qu'on m'a dit d'aller
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
moi
voilà ça n'arrête le sont alors je
pousse un peu les traits et vous avez ça
à la bouche un peu du coup j'y suis allé
un peu trop fort je pousse un peu le
trait mais vous avez une fonction qui
est intéressante j'y vais fort c'est à
dire qu'en fait vous avez pas besoin de
taper sur vos buzz pour rien
activer/désactiver leçons vous le faites
sur un bout de votre visage là je tape
deux fois samedi à la musique un peu
plus fort voilà donc là j'ai la musique
hier par trois fois voilà la musique ça
alors ça va changer de morceau ou trois
fois c'est que c'est pas du paramètre
est comme ça donc bon
deux fois des bases à deux fois play
deux fois pose trois fois morceau
suivant donc là six jours avec la
musique donc là j'ai la musique alors là
jour où chaque je veux arrêter la
musique voilà ça arrête la musique alors
en fait on se parle de sartre ce sont
les lignes bugs de ceux y est c'est
vachement intéressant pourquoi parce que
en fait sony c'est une boîte quand ils
vont vous proposer de l'audio des
écouteurs c'est plus destiné par dtcc
hausse mais à des gens qui s'intéressent
qui aime aller gratouiller il veut une
expérience de l'application complète et
qui aime bien les produits où on sait
qu'on peut aller dedans et qu'on va
mettre en face d'autres marques comme
des bosses et du plug and play on s'en
remet pas ici c'est pas qu'on s'embête
si c'est qu'on peut aller loin c'est
qu'on peut venir paramétrer vous avez le
ds qui va faire de même ce qui est
vraiment qu'il ya plein d'options on va
regarder dans l'application de quelques
instants et c'est la première fois que
l'on voit arriver sony avec un produit
déjà qui a pas un nom à coucher dehors
on n'est pas serein wf medx m4 on n'est
pas sur un w h music scene cap on est
sur une ligne buzz donc on est sur un
produit plus marque était au niveau du
nom et ça montre que sony veut aller
chercher une nouvelle cible ils veulent
aller sur autres d'autres personnes et
ça c'est vachement intéressant parce que
ça monte cette volonté d'ouverture cette
volonté d'aller conquérir de nouveaux
marchés et les voir une nouvelle cible
alors vous le voyez les lignes bugs et
ça et ça c'est vachement marrant
pourquoi parce que si vous avez regardé
de très près en est quand même
relativement près vous avez un trou au
centre et ce trou il fait quoi et bien
il reste pas c'est le son là c'est un
trou enfin d'un trou c'est un trou donc
le son va passer à travers donc c'est
vraiment la volonté de se dire on est
ouvert on est ouvert sur le monde et on
veut entend ce qui se passe autour de
nous si par exemple vous prenez dwf
1000x m4 vous allez avoir une réduction
de bruit active vous allez pouvoir
activer un autre transparence par les
micros vous injectera du son et vous
permettra d'entendre alors après il ya
différents niveaux peu à regret des
choses mais le son vient des micros mais
la leçon ne vient pas des micros la
leçon
bien c'est de l'acoustique pur et dur ça
vienne l'extérieur donc c'est assez
intéressant et là vous y retrouver
ensuite votre système de haut parleurs
qui se situe juste là ici vous avez
votre petit capteur de présence pour
savoir bien s'ils sont posés là là on a
de quoi venir leurs charges et ça c'est
une petite ailette on en a plusieurs
pour venir adapté à taille de votre
oreille et puis voilà that's it 1 ça
marche comme ça alors regardez je vous
montre comment ça s'insère dans le rail
vient là toi mon lapin est parfaite vous
prenez comme ça vous le glisser à
l'intérieur de l'oreille et les liens se
coincer sur le l'oreille mais voilà on
ne pose juste on vient juste le poser
délicatement et la même chose peut être
gênante et mieux vous le prenez comme ça
ça vient juste posé dans fait aérien qui
rentre voilà vous mettez et l'ailette
elle doit venir se poser ensuite au
niveau de notre conduit auditif ici est
ce qui fait qu en fait eh bien vous avez
un truc qui est juste posé à l'entrée de
l'oreille donc en termes de tenue en
termes de confort alors une fois que
vous avez trouvé chez les mal positionné
une fois que vous avez trouvé la taille
qui correspond à votre oreille basse et
c'est un peu tout con ça tient plutôt
pas mal alors on peut épiloguer je sais
pas si on peut durer pendant des hommes
on peut lire joggé on va éviter de
pogoter mais en tout cas bon la tenue
elle est plutôt intéressante alors pour
venir avoir justement une bonne tenue eh
bien on va avoir le choix au niveau de
notre petit package y regarder tout est
rangé là alors ils ont vraiment son
emballage carton nous on est ok on éco
responsable et on fait gaffe et on met
du carton et on n'est pas du plastique
ça s'est très très bien à trois tailles
en fait du cap d'ail excusez-moi xs s l
et xl pour mieux s'adapter aux oreilles
de tout un chacun donc dans l'idée why
not on va retrouver un petit câble de
rechargement moi j'ai des câbles
universo universelle universal je sais
pas moi via les câbles que je vais
utiliser de cellules usb usb c'est vous
avez surtout un petit boîtier de
recharge là qui est en train de
recharger justement lui à ce centre
c'est un petit écrin aux plats on louvre
vous venez posez ensuite vos buzz à
l'intérieur il se recharge très
simplement bon on connaît le système
c'est très simple vous le prenez vous le
posez vous voyez votre niveau et si ça
vous donne une idée et ensuite vous
l'ouvrez alors y'a un truc je me suis
dit quand j'ai touché du tiens c'est
marrant ça bouge un peu ce truc est ce
que ils n'ont pas voulu gagner un peu
surpris d'avoir truc un peu moins
premium mais c'est très honnêtement je
trouve ça bien ça fonctionne bien et
puis pour moi c'est pas vraiment le truc
on va se dire et il faut pas ça vous
choquer un accompagnement de la rigidité
non ça marche vous le recharger derrière
le petit bouton ici pour venir les
appéré tout en sachant qu'ici vous avez
dû face père enfin vous pouvez repérer
très facilement sur android mais
également sur un pc alors il fonctionne
également à ios 5 sans aucun problème
application ios et android donc ça ira
très très bien alors y'a plein de trucs
intéressants à dire moi je trouve que
l'idée marketing allait pas mal de se
dire j'ai des petits bugs je viens
déposer gelé mais là je viens chercher
une cible un peu plus jeunes un très
clairement ici im en même temps écouter
de la musique mais pas forcément formé
qui veulent en même temps pouvoir la
suivre un cours qui veulent pouvoir en
même temps discuter avec des amis tout
en ayant cette ambiance musicale c'est
vraiment l'idée on est vraiment là
dessus on n'est pas sourd idée du
mélomane qui veut sa musique sa but on
sort terme ici on s'enferme pas si vous
voulez vous enfermez avec ça vous
n'allez jamais y arriver physiquement ce
n'est pas possible donc on est sur cette
nouvelle cible ok jusqu'au la samba
maintenant il ya un truc que je trouve
plutôt marrant c'est je vous le dis ce
côté play pause j'appuie deux fois tant
les voilages épique octobre jean temps
là il me remet la musique jeu rapide
deux fois s'arrête donc ça c'est bien
mais voilà il a eu il ya une gym un peu
fort grossi très il ya un truc qui est
cool mais il ya un truc que je trouve
aussi un peu plus ample un peu moins
c'est lorsque j'étais en appel
téléphonique alors on peut passer des
coups de fil à des cons sont tous très
bien alors je sais pas ce que je me suis
grattée est ce que je me suis appuyé a
été trop fort par deux fois ça a
raccroché bon peut-être qu'il faut venir
régler régler la sensibilité
ça c'est un chiffre que nous donne sony
nous annonce qui sont 51 % plus compact
que les wf 1000 x m 4 on a aussi un
boîtier qui est un peu plus petit 1 2
26% broc et ça à ceux des chiffres ils
sont assez légers en fait 4,1 g par
écouteurs bon ça me semble bien ici
alors ce qu'il faut savoir et si c'est
qu'on va retrouver le même processeur
qu'on a sur les wf mellick cmkd donc
processeurs haut de gamme de chez sony
vous avez tout un côté algorithmique que
vient maîtriser son lit c'est à dire
qu'ils vont venir notamment lors de vos
appels téléphoniques venir supprimés
pour la personne qui vous entend
supprimer les bruits environnants pour
ne se concentrer que sur votre voix
alors ça c'est bien sauf que vous
lorsque si vous passez un appel dans la
rue il ya beaucoup de circulation de la
même manière que si vous allez écouter
de la musique dans la rue eh bien on va
pas venir supprimer le bruit autour de
vous si vous voulez passer un coup de
fil j'en sais rien moi dans un métro
dans un bus alors qu'il ya beaucoup de
bruit à là ça va être compliqué alors
peut-être que la personne à l'autre bout
du fil vous entendra bien grasse à tous
le traitement algorithmique qu'il va y
avoir mais vous vous allez rien entendre
ou très peu savent être gênant alors
qu'est ce qu'on vient faire quand on
entend mal eh bien on vient montrent
elles sont alors on peut effectivement
mais est ce que c'est vraiment l'idée
savary que certains cas d' usage mois
typiquement tout à l'heure je me balade
au moment où j'ai été filmé cette
première partie alors il ya des gens
dont il ya des rues un peu plus calme et
il n'y a aucun problème j'entends c'est
une voiture qui allait où j'entends des
gens autour de moi et se passe des
choses mais lorsque je suis sur un
boulevard où il ya beaucoup de bruit
c'est pénible du coup j'ai fait quoi je
pousse le son à fond et est ce que c'est
vraiment la bonne idée je ne suis pas
sûr est ce que c'est ce que je vais
préférer m'envoyer sur dwf melix m4 ou
consorts est bien c'est que j'ai pas
besoin de mettre le son trop fort pour
profiter d'une bonne expérience et je
vais pas être tout le temps le son à
fond parce que si vous allez vous
balader dix minutes un quart d'heure et
que vous montez le son à ce moment là
bon c'est dix minutes un quart d'heure
mais si vous décidez je sais pas si vous
marchez une demi-heure une heure le son
à fond avec beaucoup de bruit il ya un
truc un peu limitatif il ya un truc qui
n'est pas forcément bon pour l'oreille
donc il faut vraiment savoir à quel
moment va venir l'utiliser de quelle
manière je le verrais bien complément
d'un de buzz ou dos casque à réduction
de bruit on va pouvoir venir se fermer
davantage mais tout seul d'avoir
uniquement en buzz principale ou en
système d août portatif principal ben je
trouve qu'il ya un moment où
il va souffrir un peu de son usage
premier à savoir laisser passer elles
sont donc il ya des choses très bien il
y en a d'autres qui le sont un peu moins
alors il ya d'autres trucs qu'on va
retrouver ici chez sonic en trouve dans
d'autres bugs comme vous avez un petit
détecteur de présence là qui va se
situer juste là lorsque vous les enlevez
la musique se met en pause bon vous avez
pas besoin c'est pas dans l'adn de ces
écouteurs de se dire on les enlève
puisque vous avez un trou dont vous avez
juste à vous taper sur le côté ou vous
mettre des grandes gifles comme vous
voulez dans les deux cas ça fonctionnera
bien pour venir couper et de toute façon
entendre sans rien du tout ce qui se
passe autour de vous par ici on est
compatible évidemment google assistant
également amazon avec ça et vous avez
une fonctionnalité je voudrais dans
l'application s'appelle le speak to chat
qui nous l'avait montré déjà avec
notamment les wf music scene cas c'est à
dire que lorsque vous activer cette
fonctionnalité au moment où vous vous
venez parler ça doit arrêter la musique
par exemple vous rentrez dans un magasin
comme égal petit trouve n'ai pas besoin
de vous embêter alors autant avec dwf
melix mk parce que c'est ce qui va se
passer eh bien lorsque vous allez
rentrer dans un magasin et bientôt
explique tout chat c'est l'avenir
actionner le sons environnants ça vous
permettra d'entendre tout ce qui se
passe autour de vous et devenir
converser donc vous rentrez dans un
magasin avec wmx m 4 nages réduction de
bruit active où commençait à parler et
là ça s'ouvre et on parle vous montre à
quoi une demi seconde une seconde sur le
son extérieur donc des fonds a tendance
à venir les enlever la de toute façon
comme s'est ouvert vous entendrez si
vous êtes arrivé avec la musique pas
trop fort et bien ça ira sinon vous
commencez à parler si vous actionnez le
speak to chat eh bien ça comptera la
musique et vous pourrez converser sans
aucune pollution dans vos oreilles si
encore on peut considérer que la musique
est une pollution dans ce cas là à voir
un des usages fort ici on le voit du
fait que ce soit ouvert comme ça c'est
d'aller faire du sport d'aller courir
d'aller en extérieur pour savoir ce qui
se passe autour de soi et quand on court
qu'est ce qui se passe on transpire en
règle générale et si on a des écouteurs
qui sont annoncés résistant à l'eau et à
la transpiration donc vous pouvez aller
faire du sport avec son problème niveau
autonomie qu'est ce que nous annonce
sony alors nous annonce une autonomie
jusqu'à 17h 50 avec le boîtier et les
écouteurs et puis une coup de charges en
dix minutes vous gagnez une heure et
demie de musique et par écouteurs vous
aller jusqu'à 5 heures cinquante et une
charge de boîtiers vous emmènera à 12
heures chez sony on a une application
elle est très bien fait donc si vous ne
la connaissez pas et si vous n'êtes pas
encore rentré chez sony je vais vous
montrer pour le découvrir mais vous
allez voir de toute façon pour moi c'est
une des meilleures si ce n'est la
meilleure application au niveau de
l'audio donc ça c'est vachement cool et
ils ont forcément emmené sa également la
même manière des lignes buzz donc ici
l'appli elle veut absolument que je
regarde le didacticiel mais j'ai pas
envie tout il écrit en japonais donc on
va éviter de passer pour moi j'ai une
version démo vous vous aurez une version
qui ira très bien donc ne vous inquiétez
pas je vois effectivement mais niveau de
batterie ça me paraît assez normal alors
ici j'ai l'état si je vais dans l'état
je vois la musique que j'écoutais un
petit pic histoire de se mettre dans
l'ambiance en dessous je vais avoir le
casque activités informations on regarde
ça dans quelques instants alors on
s'intéresse à la partie sont ils sûrs
vie active et le speak to chat donc
lorsque j'appuie y voyez hop là et
lorsque j'appuie comme ça qu'est ce que
ça fait pas ça va couper la musique pour
reconnaître le moment où je parle j'ai
également un petit paramètres
sensibilité à la voix automatique ou
temps de fermeture du mode standard je
peux venir le faire un très très court
standard 15 secondes lente ces moments
vous arrêtez de parler en fait donc si
vous arrêtez de parler et que ça remet
la musique à chaque fois nous avons en
avoir marre parce que des fois on ne
parle pas tout le temps si on est par
exemple dans un magasin ou en train
d'échanger j'en sais rien moi chez
stardom ce compagnie donc vous le
laissez ici en 15 secondes c'est pas mal
vous avez également la sensibilité à la
voix faible élevé est ok why not on va
alors moi je le laisse pas parce que
c'est pas un truc que tu vas trop
intéressé on a également un égalisé
avant que c'est vachement cool alors moi
je me suis fait un petit paramétrage
comme ça en mode personnalisé c'est ce
que je vous conseille de faire ingérer
réhaussé très légèrement vers 400 kg et
ensuite j'ai monté légèrement les aigus
à 2 5 6 3 et 16 et puis j'ai poussé le
cuir base parce que au niveau du son si
vous voulez je trouve que de par la
fabrication même de ces bugs dont va
manquer de rondeur aux banques est grave
on va manquer de sensations qui va vous
faire vibrer on n'est plus sûr du médium
alors pour autant ça reste bien ça reste
assez précis on n'a pas un son qui va
être médium très étriqué on est très
content centrant son mondial on inspecte
qui est quand même assez large sur les
fréquences médium puis pas trop dire
médium grave si un peu médium grave on
va aller sur du médium aigu mais j'aime
bien rajouter un petit peu de clarté
avec les fréquences à 6,3 attention si
vous avez de la sibylle ans ici on n'a
pas de sybille ans parce que sinon à 6,3
ça serait pas terrible et rajouter
vraiment de la clarté au niveau des
cymbales à 16 kilos c'est des choses que
j'aime bien voyez ça rajoute un peu
d'ouverture il faut y aller doucement
sur ces coalisant là parce que si vous
le poussez trop sur les hautes
fréquences ça va être trop poussif et
c'est parce que je viens vous vous
recommander mai
légèrement augmenté pour ajouter un peu
de clarté ça me paraît pas mal comme on
est sur du médium je pousse pas au
niveau de 1 kg pour est le cas c'est
légèrement mais pas trop et je vous dis
on vient chercher à monter un peu au
niveau 400 hertz j'aurais aimé pouvoir
aller un peu en dessous venir chercher
du 250r devoir du 100 m dont j'allais
récupérer ici avec la fonctionnalité clé
rabat ce que j'ai poussé au match parce
que pour moi ici comme j'ai pas assez de
basse ça m'embête alors après vous avez
d'autres modes qui existe mais pour moi
ils sont pas assez bons pour ce que je
vais rechercher mois en terme d' écoute
donc les mots de personnaliser un mur à
bien tout en sachant que vous pouvez
avoir un mode personnalisé 2 ou
carrément le désactiver moi je vous
conseille de venir faire votre propre
équaliseur en fonction de ce que vous
allez aimer écouter on va également
avoir le 360 reality audio la connexion
bluetooth moi j'ai mis la priorité à la
qualité sonore on peut le mettre à une
connexion stable mais moi je demi comme
ça pour avoir la meilleure expérience
audio le ds eux en automatique le dsc
quoi sa noble stealing au niveau du son
ça vient augmenter de façon artificielle
la qualité de votre son ca fais pas de
la magie message ou un petit quelque
chose et c'est quand même plutôt pas mal
au niveau de la partie système on va
voir un contrôle adaptatif du volume
s'est désactivé parce que je préfère
venir le régler vraiment manuellement
ici c'est intéressant parce que vous me
réglez votre fonction de pape en fait
sur l'oreille droite et l'oreille gauche
donc la bruine je vais taper deux fois
et j'ai tapé trois fois donc la gemmi
augmenté volumes baisser le volume sur
leur gauche mais j'ai le choix avec le
contrôle de la lecture donc les punks le
fait de sélection d'un morceau les
fonctions d'assistance vocale amazon
avec ça ou alors carrément rien du tout
pour moi le volume c'est ce qui
conviendra le mieux ici et sur la partie
droite j'ai mis donc deux fois play
pause et trois fois morceau suivant
voyez comme ça on l'a et ça fonctionne
on vient activé en marquant taper sur
une vaste zone ça c'est vachement cool
et c'est ce que je vous propose en plus
du casque donc on peut taper sur le
casse mais c'est parce nous intéresse
nous intéresser la vaste zone c les
retaper sur votre visage pour me
relancer par exemple voilà celle active
voilà là c'est très vaste comme
j'étais trop nous
j'exagère avec ces chiffres parce qu'en
fait que bute sait pas d'où m'est déjà
arrivée notable
voilà ça reconnaît alors il faut quand
même que le double table soit
suffisamment fort pour qu'il le capt
voilà il le cap il faut s'y reprendre à
deux trois fois il faut avoir l'habitude
de squatter petite tape sur la tronche
mais c'est pas mal et je trouve ça assez
rigolo puis y'a un côté marketing
marrant alors la grosse gifle non mais
la petite tape c'est pas mal et puis
après on a d'autres fonctionnalités
pour avoir votre voix en français et
après il n'y a pas de service votre
activité au quai quelques informations
bon ok on va pas c'est donc ton post
application elle est complète elle est
vachement bien notamment au niveau de
l'équateur nearparent à mettre au niveau
du tap donc ça j'aime bien et je trouve
ça très très bien sonnés et on le voit
un sony vient vraiment chercher cette
nouvelle cible à la genzyme les plus
jeunes d'entre nous qui se font draguer
de plus en plus et à qui on va pas venir
dans dwf 1000 x n 4 qui coûte quand même
relativement cher on est sur un tarif à
199 euros ça reste quand même élevé
attention on est possible dans le haut
du panier tout en sachant qu'ici à 199
euros on n'a pas de réduction de bruit
actif donc c'est vrai que je les aurai
plus vu déjà 179 euros ça ne paraîtrait
un peu plus dans la course je trouve
qu'ils sont un peu chers 179 balle on
économiserait 20 euros on viendrait se
mettre en frontal avec d'autres
fabricants qui
non pas forcément réduction de bruit
active alors attention parce qu'il ya
réduction de bruit active à l'adduction
d'eau réactif vous avez certains
fabricants qui à 99 euros vous mettre de
la réduction collective mais ces
histoires de ce marais il se produira
contenu tout autre histoire donc on veut
pas avoir de la réduction d'objectif
c'est parce qu'on a cherché c'est tout
nouveau est ce que je trouve aussi très
intéressant ici et j'aime bien le parti
pris que fait sony c'est à dire que on
voit beaucoup d'écouteurs arrivé il y en
a tous les côtés toutes les marques sont
leurs buzzer écouteurs avec des formes
qui sont toujours un peu les mêmes même
s'il ya des petites modifications de
céder petite différence qui se racontent
souvent un peu la même histoire là c'est
une nouvelle histoire et c'est ça qui va
vraiment me meut singer dans ce produit
je vous dis hein il a plein de petites
limites notamment sur des des endroits
un peu bruyant mais ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est cette innovation l'idée
de se dire ok on va laisser passer le
son on va laisser circuler directement
parce que ça va correspondre à un usage
est qu'à un usage voilà on va pas
chercher ici à toucher les mélomanes qui
veulent sans fermer on vient vraiment
chercher cette cible plus jeune la jay z
qui veut consommer de la musique tout le
temps on pouvant vivre sa vie de vie
active sans s'y limiter sens bloqué six
a donc l'idéal est là l'idéal est plutôt
marrante est ce que pour autant legend
of zelda 899 euros dans des écouteurs je
ne suis pas convaincu on verra le sony
nous racontera ou pas si ça a fonctionné
ou pas ces écouteurs il existe tout en
blanc ou en noir comme ça on reste dans
la sobriété et l'efficacité ça marche
voilà moi écouter l'expérience je trouve
bien jeu j'aime bien l'idée j'aime bien
ce système de tape sur le côté j'aime
bien effectivement de pouvoir avoir de
la musique en entendant ce qui se passe
mais de façon naturelle grâce à ce petit
trou là il ya effectivement des plus de
limites mais dans l'idée c'est un truc
qui me séduit assez ce que ça peut vous
séduire vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous de ces lignes buzz de sunir
que vous êtes hype et papiers du tout
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tandis que le mans commenta parce que je
suis très curieux moi j'ai trouvé
intéressante quitte moi ce que vous en
pensez on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler telle qu'on va parler
de sony on va tester d'autres produits
soyez cool soyez rassurés ça va être
cool j'avais plus à parler allez vous
embrasse cheveux asiatiques
[Musique]